halo ist ein freundlicher kopfhörer
aufgesammelt lokführer auf
dementsprechend ist es zeit für einen
zweiten teil von sandra huber reden mit
kopfhörern bereden einfachen geräten
einfach
wir redeten
regel sehr gute talente
was an dass die spenden und morgen werde
ich die enten füttern branche überaus
teilte heute mit dass wir versuchen
wirklich unterhaltung überhaupt so
panisch versucht hat früher fast
geklappt ich schaffe es nicht
[Musik]
freut mich ausgegrenzt
die wirtschaft
verbessere auswahl ist schön ich wohne
ja ich finde
ja mit dem ernst zum ja
wahrscheinlich noch für
videoproduktionen und kenntnissen
überhaupt kochen macht erhofft sich von
dem designer umgehen
hast du machst du auch noch oben geht
vor aber das ist ja noch sehr viel
hass ich mach das doch beachtlich ich
mache nichts
nach oben kann man noch gelassen wie man
liegt nicht da oben sondern es
soll darum gehen dahin
denn wir wollen uns jetzt mal von das
tun sagt sax und ich muss dann versuchen
das wieder zu gehen wenn man kerzen ein
jetzt können sie nicht mehr leuchten
noch mal was noch mal
jemand herzen einspielen kann man sie
nicht wieder an leuchten
wenn man herzen an leuchtet haben also
nicht wieder anlaufen
flamingos das blöde sich versteh gar
nicht was du sagen ja - wochen ein
kosten
sie ist einfach nur 100 typenschein
eine stelle bei allen seinen ersten
worten
[Musik]
normale
kleiderschrank
lockenstab intel
chips
die dieses album ein cooler weiter ich
gesagt
bin ich genauso cool macht eigentlich
erkennen dass wir beide die kopfhörer
oder schneller gelaufen
ist geschmolzen und von äußerer und ich
richtig juan
cia sind von außerordentlicher
wichtigkeit
schwarz hier
ausserordentlicher wichtigkeit
dass er
spuren sichern schweins
und
sie
hat ja schon ziehen sind zelt vom
schuljahr sind von weit
unter das ist zu einfach zu sagen
weil
hier
sind sind von
schmutziger sind von frischer wind von
der see her von
20 sind von assange monster sind von
ausserordentlicher
die gerne voraus nach ordentlicher
das ist
außerordentlich
last
transportieren
sind von ausserordentlicher normal
normal
[Musik]
ausserordentlicher
wichtigkeit
wichtigkeit der wichtigkeit des endlich
die beste
laut das ist bei dir du hast
helvetia sind von ausserordentlicher
wichtigkeit
wir tun ja so als ob ich in
unternehmenschef wäre und du willst ein
job bei mir haben
jetzt zum interview
ich freue mich heute persönlich kennen
zu lernen was sie kann das verhalten aus
das ist schön wir brauchen leute die
ärger sind sie das ist meine stärke ist
das gut
unter der woche rum kommen ich verstehe
meine eigene sätze nicht weil das gehirn
verarbeitet unter der woche ja ok dabei
kommt ich keine lust mehr jeden tag auf
dem foto rechts ich habe deutsch haben
sich der schule schriftlich um wörtlich
links und anna haag nicht nur
französische ich zum beispiel auch aber
es kann immer so gut und ich habe
deutsch und englisch fieber bis sind
was
aus dem koffer schon noch groß
geschrieben ich habe daher keinen
führerschein können sie gut wird herbert
selbst kommt nicht selten dumm weiter
aber nicht alle können das recht der
party von spreche dann gehe ich direkt
dabei ich weiß ich hab s geschafft mir
können das dann aussieht zeigen die sog
[Applaus]
hat man sich dann anfangen können das
ist jetzt mein lieber gott
du bist wunderbar alles ausgefüllt mit
bringen und sie so wasser
und vitamine dritter teams ohne das
super sie schreibt ist ohnehin
geschwächte klein daher auch nicht vom
tisch komme was richtig akzeptiert ist
vielleicht haben ja den tausenden sich
ein schwarzes hemd oder shirt
oder sich selbst genauso hotel das passt
aber es passt zu tippen da würde ich
sagen unseren dank
habe ich den ball sicher nicht erzählt
was zugesprochen du hast du gesprochen
ich dachte pattinson sprach mit kann nee
ich hab so gesagt sie haben es freut
mich sicher kennen zu lernen uns ist
kooperation ist uns wichtig ist mit
anderen mitarbeitern und klar kommen
dass sie sich auch heranziehen büro und
sondern dachte ich du sagst ja du hast
kein geld für kleine büros erstmal dafür
wie ein sprecher sagt clark soja ist
einfach dazu führerschein nicht gefallen
haben zusätzlich behindert sie wollen
aber
ich mache momentan der haben gegeben und
so bierwirth ich habe gar nichts
verstanden
[Musik]